bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on évoque donc ce back
door de quoi les usa justement les états
unis accuse-t-il
why wait see en fait c'est d'affaires a
beau bizarre parce que celui qui l'a
incluse et c'est justement celui qui
écoute les autres
même leurs alliés on sait très bien ce
qui s'est passé avec la suite des
informations diffusées par snow tonnes
et sur le projet et risme on sait très
bien les avenues on n'est jamais arrêté
de écouter les autres
alors aujourd'hui c'est les africains
qui accusent paris de le faire alors que
fabrice et cette technologie et des
biens testés par des socialistes
le technique les techniciens d'exemples
qui maîtrise de la science ont testé et
ils ont prouvé que travail ne démontre
aucune faille technologique
donc je ne pense pas que l'accusation
des avocats soient aussi cru par les
autres pays alors oui oui ne sera pas
écarté de la 5g en france et une
déclaration du ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire et cela en dépit des
pressions américaines sur l'europe quel
signal selon vous envoie la france
je pense que la france est un pays de
l'économie de marché ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya une règle sur ce marché là et
que le meilleur gagne et gaouaoui est
une entreprise chinoise mais elle est
aussi une entreprise française créée
avait investi en france employés des
français les techniciens des commerciaux
et c'est une reprise en créant france
donc si une entreprise investit en
france ne veulent pas participer de
façon égale à la concurrence en france
eh ben je pense que les autres
entreprises ne viendront pas en france
parce que ce n'est pas à marcher égale
donc je pense que c'est tout à fait à
signal positif et la signal de loyal
droiture de ma part de la france de ne
pas exclure huawei qui a acquis à le
seul accusateurs qui et les états unis
et alors là c'est vrai qu'il ya des
soupçons quand ma main sur la sécurité
des équipements du géant chinois des
télécoms lier d'allemagne n'a pas encore
fait connaître sa décision mais semble
vouloir suivre la france est ce que la
tendance elle est favorable pour rwe
vous pensez je pense qu'on va laisser
les socialistes devaient faire je ne
prévois rien si c'est une question
juridique il ya deux juristes qui vous
répondent
c'est une question technique il ya des
techniciens qui vont répondre je pense
que que soit la france où les autres
filles ont la capacité de juger la
meilleure solution pour eux mêmes merci
beaucoup à vous wang li pour avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions sur rt
franches afin que vous êtes le directeur
général de viatique chine merci